لقد وجدت الكثير من الأشياء من خلال هذا البحث ،
وجدت الحب في الأجزاء ، ولم
أكن أتوقع أبدًا أن [موسيقى] أولئك الذين وجدت لهم هدفًا لحياتي ،
أنا تحت قيادة كوينتيرو ، أنا فنان بدوي
وأنا في ملحمة  البحث بين
جميع المتنزهات الوطنية البالغ عددها 61 في الولايات
المتحدة ، فأنا متأكد من أن المنتزهات الوطنية التي
توضح جمال
هذه الأماكن المقدسة ومشاركتها مع
العالم هناك حديقة وطنية جديدة هنا
في إنديانا إنديانا ديونز ناشيونال
بارك وهي مكان جميل حقًا
أكثر  لا يعتقد الناس أن إنديانا
لديها كثبان رملية هنا في Mount Baldy
على ارتفاع 123 قدمًا فوق بحيرة ميشيغان ،
لذا يمكنك رؤية الكثبان الرملية التي يمكن أن ترتفع إلى
حد كبير ، حتى أن بعضها على طول
شاطئ البحيرة هذا الذي يبلغ ارتفاعه حوالي 200 قدم ،
كانت هناك أشياء مدهشة.  اليوم
هو لون الماء هنا في
بحيرة ميشيغان ، لون الماء
الذي تعتقد أنه مثل الشاطئ الكوري ،
أحد أكثر الأشياء إرضاءً من
هذا ، وليس نمط حياتي هو أنه يمكنك
الاستيقاظ تحت الإعلان  إذا كانت السماء غير مألوفة كل يوم ، فإن
عدم اليقين هو أمر جيد حقًا
ومن الجيد أن تفاجئ نفسك بأن
الشعور يحررك حقًا ويمنحك
الحرية التي لم يسبق لها مثيل.